some of your closest friends seem more
like family sierra
and vanessa bryant it brings people joy
to see you all post these videos of the
kids
you all hanging out how does it feel to
know that your friendships are creating
these
lifelong bonds between your kids now
like oh we love that
to me is the the just one of the most
important parts you know this have
our kids be able to grow up together and
you know they look at themselves as
cousins and they do
do a lot together and kyan's the oldest
but all the kids look up to cayenne and
what does cayenne thing call cayenne
pepper my poor cayenne's like
okay you know everybody wants to talk to
cayenne but it's really cool just to see
our kids grow up together and be able to
have so many great experiences together
you want that
you know as friends so that's a
beautiful thing to see yeah
and i want to ask you about um capri
bianca natalia if you don't feel
comfortable answering that's totally
fine i just wanted to know
how has it been for you being able to
see them grow over the last
past few months i've seen them grow
their entire lives so you know i've been
a part of their lives from
before they were even even even thought
of so just to
continue to be a part of their journey
is is amazing and to be
auntie lala and always be there for them
no matter what is
is an amazing thing and a responsibility
that you know i don't take lightly
um that's that's my family and that
that's what it's always going to be and
i'm always going to have their
best interests at heart no matter what
and do whatever i can to continue to
make sure they're
happy and smiling and enjoying life and
and just being great people
yeah yeah well you also built this
reputation for being such a supportive
friend
sierra look kelly vanessa the list goes
on kim
and being a supportive friend is not
always the easiest thing to do being a
good friend
is not always the easiest thing to do so
what do you attribute your long-lasting
relationships to
um i definitely think i'm someone who's
easy to talk to i'm a cancer and if you
know anything about the zodiac cancers
are just
loving sensitive caring people and i
think that's who i am and
easy to talk to i definitely pride
myself in like no judgment you can tell
me anything
one it's secret's always gonna be safe
with me and two it's no judgment i'll
give honest real advice but
it's not like you know you shouldn't be
doing that you like that's just right
my way i'm just like okay let's talk
through this and let me give you the
pros and let me give you the cons
and um i love my friends and i love
having such a
supportive group of girlfriends that you
know i can go to for anything that are
all like
successful in multiple areas of their
life is really cool to have them as
a sounding board and i know who to call
for what whatever's going on like okay
that that that's a kelly thing that's a
sierra thing that's a good thing like i
know
and it's great to have on that support
system it's so crazy because i mean as i
get older
it's not easy keeping genuine
relationships with
girlfriends so it's definitely inspiring
when you just see all of you all are
beautiful and successful in your own
right
thank you and you are genuine to one
another so i love that
well we've watched you go through so
many ups and downs throughout your life
just because you've been in the
spotlight for so long
something i admire about you is that you
always put your family first
you tune out the negative opinions and
you stay strong and do what you feel
like is best
just for some advice woman to woman how
do you do that because
it's not an easy thing to just tune out
what everyone says
and do what you know is best for you um
you just have to figure out
whose opinion really matters to you like
to me my opinion and my families who are
the people that really know me
is what matters to me yours might just
be your own opinion but
you can't let the opinions of the entire
world
hold that much weight and especially
when you're dealing with people that
don't even
know you that only know you on the
surface and we live in a world where
someone's always gonna have something to
say and as long as you know that
but you're living in your truth and you
know the people that you care about
know whatever the journey is then that's
what's most important and it's not easy
i mean i had to learn that and
we're only human you know things affect
me sometimes or i can
hear something and i'm like why would
somebody say that they don't even know
me you know you still have those moments
but
overall i've just gotten better at you
know figuring out what's important whose
opinion is important and really
focusing on that